josée legault à la question gay
christian dufour bonsoir bonsoir passé
soit je vais quand même vous parler un
petit bout on va parler du débat de tva
ce soir on va mettre la table puis je
vais vous écoutez mes cheveux quand même
vous parler de ce rapport préliminaire
c'est le deuxième rapport préliminaire
de johan castonguay commissaire à la
santé sur ce qui est arrivé le drame
dans l'essai chez celles des ce que
c'est moi où j'ai eu de la difficulté va
danser avec vous à lek je sais pas si
vous l'avez fait ce midi à votre
émission mais là j'ai l'impression que s
caudéra vous avez écrit un livre on va
des rapports puis finalement à la fin de
la journée on comprendre on rit
on va comprendre qu'il y avait une
désorganisation totale dans le réseau
mais c'est parce qu'en fait on commence
à avoir une bonne idée de ce qui s'est
passé on a eu beau moi j'écris un livre
sur le sujet la protectrice du citoyen
fêtera par quand même assez étoffé sur
le sujet le johann castonguay avait
arrive avec son rapport c'est pas
inutile c'est toujours des exercices qui
sont utiles pour bien cerner ce qui
s'est passé mais il n'y a pas beaucoup
de nouveautés et au delà de 10 qui avait
une énorme d organisation n'a pas pris
les décisions au bon moment on a été
surpris de l'arrivée du virus dans le
csld on manquait de personnel ont manqué
de gestionnaire il y avait des
gestionnaires qui tombait malade et
avait par exemple les codes pour savoir
qui entre et qui entrait pas au travail
puis bon comme ils sont malades puis
personne c'est qui qui qui vont rentrer
au travail des aberrations le personal
code pour un système informatique moment
donné c'est qu'on commence à en avoir eu
beaucoup de ces histoires mais je ne
vous oublie pas j'ose écrire mes alec
vous êtes moi je veux savoir
pourquoi la section hospitalière avec
aux peintures unis la cheminée c'était
hyper hyper prête à le combat puis la
section
résidence personnes âgées sa chasse ldc
comme rester est ce que quelqu'un
pourrait m'expliquer sa monnaie mais on
peut on peut quand même au fil du temps
mieux comprendre ce qui s'est passé
c'est que la réponse est on voudrait
qu'elle soit précise en un moment où y
ait une réunion où saponé abordés on
voudrait qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui soit
fautif mais le système des ch et celle
des est tellement depuis longtemps
j'ai d'un pearl johan castonguay en
parallèle le distingue drame collectif
que plusieurs gouvernements devraient
partager mais c'est ce qui peut être un
peu fort chance et que ça a été
tellement négligé depuis longtemps que
ces entrées un peu comme dans les moeurs
que ce système que les sèche c'est
dépassant deuxième puis bon on n'a pas
été capables à la trappe est un petit
mot rapidement parce que je veux parler
du débat quand même ce soir josé un
petit mot là dessus
c'est que la première vague était
révélateur de tout ce qui ne
fonctionnait pas avant la première vague
est comme ça a été une tempête parfaite
peut évidemment toutes les faiblesses
très grave non seulement du réseau des
cff ch et celle des mets de tout ce que
j'appelle au québec le prendre soin des
personnes vulnérables à toutes les
ressources d'hébergement que ce soit
pour les adultes handicapés
intellectuels physiques que ce soit pour
les personnes âgées qui sont en perte
d'autonomie ça fait 30 ans patrice
trentin que les gouvernements successifs
ont négligé toutes ces personnes là sous
financement des organisations
évidemment les réponses barea plus de
trois centrales isation ça a été le coup
de grâce parce que là plus personne
n'était responsable des qui que ce soit
ou de quoi que ce soit moi ce que je
sais ce qu'il faut québec sq pour
compliquer c'est une commission
d'accueil publics sur tout ça pas un
silo pour un petit morceau sur tout ça
quel des quelle société voulons-nous
commun voulons nous traiter nos
personnes vulnérables aux fontenelles 21
jours christian
en attendant il ya quand même un rapport
qu'on attend dans deux mois le rapport
de madame catholique je trouve que votre
entretien avec madame castonguay et est
très révélateur patrice et je partage
que la frustration que je sens parce
qu'à plusieurs reprises j'avais essayé
de l'avenue se perd un peu plus contre
un qui va vous parler de sa mission son
mandat il ya vraiment un problème de
culture bureaucratique là dedans parce
qu'on contrôle c'est qu'il ya un
problème d'information c'est que la main
gauche aussi parce que fait la droite le
sommet ne sais pas ce que fait la base
et même madame cas celui qui a eu
plusieurs rapports dans le passé qui est
intéressant mais aucun d'eux ne pas de
discuter moi ce que je crains c'est que
son rapport est exactement la même je
vais même solution c'est que je sois un
autre rapport aux pratiques qui s'ajoute
à tout le reste est ce que j'espère
l'aca rapport préliminaire bon j'imagine
qu'à votre appel écoute des commentaires
seraient possibles car nous arrive avec
quelque chose de sain de concret des
recommandations on dirait qu'il ya un
jargon bureaucratique dont on n'est
jamais capable de sortir sinon mais qui
en face aux des commissions comme ça
pour beaucoup il trace qu'elle vous a
répondu le moment dans ce combat mission
de ce pacte et ce droit imaginez ce qui
nous a pas cependant ses missions elle
focalisée sur sa mission d'après de
focaliser sur le problème parce que
c'est
important d'autant plus que la réponse
vers ac dc a pas de commission d'
enquête publique c'est parce qu'on fait
confiance dans madame castonguay pour
aller au fond des choses c'était la
réponse du gouvernement
car la réponse à venir donc faux car oui
c'est intéressant
la façon d'efforts pour qu'on s'en
occupe oui georges et l'inclusion et
elle n'a pas les ressources pour le
faire c'est le premier problème alors
c'est pour ça que ça prenne comme son
enquête publique et il faut aller au
fond des choses sinon comment faire du
tout ça pour ça on en
parlait josé entouré ce pont de parler
clairement pour par le français qu les
besoins en eau les citoyens et pour
arrêter d'avoir le jargon bureaucratique
dont on n'est jamais capable
on a besoin de ressources pour faire une
enquête
ouais quand même premier débat et les
entrevues dimanche très bien
informative on est très contents
beaucoup de gens là devraient des bosses
ce soir le premier en français en aura
un autre en français la semaine
prochaine face à face alors je vous
laisse libre là je vous laisse les
choisissez un chef il ya les questions
clés c'est qui le plus à perdre qu'à
gagner mais c'est quand même important
parce que les aiguilles et alex cosec
vous bougez quand même là ça se promène
dans tous les sens le honnêtement les
deux premières semaines ont été dures
échauffement ce conte aussi c'est que la
course elle est très serré on pourrait
pas ce soir 10 qui remporté un
gouvernement minoritaire ce que ce
serait conservateur-libéral la course au
bloc québécois se déroule certainement
pas commis françois blanchet l'avait
prévu non plus donc tout le monde
beaucoup de pression ce soir le soin
pour consolider les gains qu'ils ont
fait je pensais renault tôt soit pour
être capable de remonter la pente justin
trudeau sa glissade semble être terminée
mais on est loin de ce qu'ils espéraient
yves françois blanchet aussi le doit pas
juste se préoccuper de justin trudeau
doit commencer à se préoccuper des
rennes aux tours qui monte au québec qui
s'appelle du côté des sièges donc je
voudrais qu'à part jack médecine qui au
québec des ambitions modestes idéalement
s'ils pouvaient ajouter un ou deux
députés alexandre boulerice serais bien
content mais sinon les trois autres le
seront ce soir on s'adresse aux
québécois pour la première fois depuis
la dernière fois donc en 2019 l'impact
de ce dépôt avait été énorme sur la
campagne à la fois du bloc et du parti
conservateur donc ce soir certainement
que les attentes sont élevées pour tout
le monde j'osais vous sauvez qui en
particulier
je surveillais les deux les deux
principaux justin trudeau et à renault
autour d' parce que soi que le premier
ministre va rester premier ministre
qu'il va y avoir un nouveau preuve c'est
vraiment la lutte est âpre et ces deux
hommes là qu'est parti libéral est parti
conservateur
justin trudeau a repris un peu du poil
de la bête et l'énergie avec la question
des vaccinations obligatoires en tenant
tête aux manifestants les complétistes
qui suit partout mais là il faut que
cette énergie la hausse se traduise un
comme intéressant ne t'ont vraiment
tourné vers l'avenir et je sais que
c'est difficile nous on peut et on est
des gérants d'estrade mais l'avenir ça
c'est très important pour nous parce
qu'ils demandent un troisième mandat
c'est parier sur un troisième mandat
pour un premier ministre et donc oui à
la pandémie mais de quel canada aussi
voulons-nous et des quelque 1 aide
qu'elle canada il va nous proposer et la
même chose pour un bruno tour quelle
canada il va proposer moi c'est ça que
j'ai sauvée christian
moi j'ai erré d'hôtel que je surveillais
essentielle ment c'est très important
pour lui parce qu'il s'adresse pas juste
aux québécois c'est que ce avoir un
impact aussi sur l'ensemble du pays puis
la campagne commence pour la plupart des
citoyens jusqu'à présent sur vaisseau
distraitement l'aube à la fin de l'été
est ce qu'il va être capable de
continuer sur sa lancée sur son image
positive bon ben c'est pas encore fait
pas son français quand même pas
extraordinaire il va être attaqué par
beaucoup de monde c'est le premier
ministre en attente qu il essaye de se
présenter contre le futur comme le futur
prince et est-ce qu'ils vont être
capables en fait de sortir de la
pandémie moi j'ai l'impression que les
canadiens sont allés de la pandémie et
que si monsieur trudeau a trop l'air du
candidat de la pandémie va secouer les
gens veulent entendre parler d'autre
chose doit être capable en fait tout en
en parlant de la pandémie tout en
restant plus centriste qu'avant car une
certaine alternance est d'incarner autre
chose parce que je trouve que bien du
mans qui est allée du système actuel de
lancer rideau tour que je vais
surveiller peut trébucher il peut
décevoir un mot sur le chef du bloc
monsieur blanche à qui l'on a vu des
flèches décochées plus en verve et
notons également qu'ils étaient pas de
sources ont dit il qui était pas dans
l'enclos québec là on sait jamais avec
la laisse sa bouche comme je disais non
ont écouté le dernier sondage de léger
rendu public mardi montraient qu'un
québécois sur deux peut encore changer
de ville c'est au québec où il ya le
plus d'un des six actuellement donc oui
il ya toujours un peu de réverbération
de céder ball en français au canada
anglais parce qu'il va voir des
commentateurs qui vont en parler puis
voir des textes mais c'est sûr que c'est
beaucoup au québec la actuellement le ce
soir que ça va se jouer on verra la
semaine prochaine ce sera un débat plus
pancanadien mais là on s'adresse
beaucoup québécois donc faudra qu'ils
françois blanchet soit à la hauteur de
sa performance la d njawe fois
de la pression supplémentaire l'ayez pas
le petit nouveau des gens l'avaient
découvert l'avait trouvé bon la dernière
fois le il traîne un bagage il ya aussi
un début de campagne où il n'ya pas de
là d'avoir du plaisir à faire campagne
et ce qu'il faudra ce soir qu'il fasse
attention à ça la réponse est oui et
donc oui et renault towey justin trudeau
parce qu'ils y ont dû demander un pas
important mais ce soir il françois
blanchet le sait sont des bols le plus
important comme il l'avait fait la
dernière fois ici y'a pas un bon débat
ça va profiter à renault tout ça va
profiter à une auto au québec si
françois blanchet par un bond des bosses
parce que quand ça décolle quand ça
baisse ça peut décoller assez vite on
l'a vu avec les taux d'urée grange la
monnaie ou un coup devant jose est alors
c'est important ils sont tous importants
on a une tête un peu moins mais ils sont
ici c'est important
oui parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui va
se passer ce soir ça c'est sûr il ya une
impression générale qui va se dégager
pas la nôtre mais celle des électeurs
alors ça ça va être très très important
et à l'école tout à fait raison sur yves
françois blanchet parce que bon la
campagne va pas super bien quoique ces
chiffres sont quand même bon encore dans
les sondages mais là il doit sauver ça
fait longtemps qu'on parle d'eux est ce
que le black et le bloc et il est
inutile à tahoua et c'est là il ya un
autre piège aussi monsieur blanchet
c'est que à québec est quelqu'un qui
s'appelle françois legault alors lui que
c'est déjà un premier ministre populaire
qui exactement sur ses étals d'ailleurs
laissé coller sur ses talons me suis
branché sur un nationalisme identitaire
et cetera et cetera alors est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il ne peut être que l' écoute
françois legault sinon ben l écho d jean
françois legault
ou est ce qu'il va être incapable de ce
jeu trouvait sur le sel lui une nation à
lui et pour le bloc oui quelle
conclusion christian c'est juste ce que
dit josée legault c'est que le phénomène
françois legault n'est pas qui peut
nuire il françois goulard qui surveille
son temps vraiment son temps il devenu p
3 regroupe un petit peu trop suffisants
faut pas oublier que jusqu'à la dernière
avec son le bloc qu'à moitié mort
beaucoup de gens disaient que c'était
fini le blog c'était comme un miracle
certains points lors de la dernière
élection il ya eu un phénomène il
françois blanchette avait la loi sur la
laïcité donc le contexte est très
différent on retrouve que rien n est
acquis pour pour le bloc et je le répète
le temps de monsieur blanchette était
trop comme triomphateur à l'avancé il
faut que tu peut se connecter à la
réalité n'est pas si rose que ça
éventuellement très bien merci de nous
avoir partagé vos analyses à très
bientôt bonne soirée au revoir